this lady stole $700 out of my wallet
then she stole $4,500 out of Scott's it
looks like there might be a thief in
Kourtney Kardashian's house on Sunday's
episode of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians Kourt seemingly faced a
legit threat in her own home it all
started when the reality star and her
staff started noticing that money was
missing and iPads were disappearing and
it didn't take long to realize that it
appeared to be an inside job then my
security who's here today just said he's
seen her two times with her flashlight
on in the office okay but wait a second
who is freaky and carrying around $700
in their wallet no no who's casually
packing $4,500 in their wallet damn
anyway moving along get this court
points out that dun dun dun there were
no cameras in the areas of the house at
the woman they thought to be the culprit
was in this is like a real whodunit
Sherlock Holmes mystery situation am i
right where is she she's downstairs
she's at the house yeah what do you know
wait wait wait you have three kids that
she's around why I even after one piece
of information like this would you go if
she just pieced it together it's got a
harken about it let's go god I love
Chloe she's a freaking woman of action
but guys that's not all it actually gets
even scarier because Kourtney believes
that the woman is looking at her texts
and has quote hacked everything she's
looking at my texts go say something up
stand your ground this is your home with
your kids put on stairs Kourtney go talk
to your security why are you texting if
someone's telling me that wait I can't
wait to hear this this is so good this
is better than Real Housewife no but
really this is better than Real
Housewives and by the time the girls get
downstairs they see a car screeching off
we need to change the iTunes password
right now we need to debug the house and
I want to take every device and
unconnect it from my phone and next time
we've learned a huge lesson they cannot
step foot in here for an interview
without us having their social name and
address court and Scott have a chat
about the whole thing and here's where
it really does get pretty freaky the
fact that she was alone with our kids
this chick was nuts man but yeah I mean
at the end of the day I wish she wasn't
doing anything around the kids so I'm
just happy she's out of here yeah they
never identify who the alleged thief was
exactly but it seems like she was a
nanny for the family but Kourt and Scott
can rest easy because the police are on
the case
I mean just the police are doing an
investigation they are yeah and it's
still moving where is she
did they go to our house did they fight
about marks you know I'm just like
moving on I don't like dwell on things
you know I obviously can't change what
happened but like anything in life I
believe that this is a big learning
lesson and I just want to start fresh
and just get this bad energy out
naturally quartz age to the house to get
rid of all those bad vibes left behind
by the thief okay the Kardashians are
just the gift that keeps on giving of
course we'll be right here to make sure
that you are all caught up on the
Kardashians so make sure to keep it
locked right here on et until next time
I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]